[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here okay finally a
month after it was announced at that
september event the new ipad air
is finally here
and it turns out if anything out there
is actually an ipad pro killer
it's this i mean i've talked at length
about how the ipad pro is my favorite
tablet by a mile right you've seen the
videos and i've also talked about how
other tablets might be better at the
ipad pro at like one thing like maybe a
better overall display or a better
speaker setup but overall the whole
package for best tablet for me
keeps going to ipad pro but the thing is
most people don't need an ipad pro and
that thing still starts at 800 bucks but
now with all the updates to this 4th gen
ipad air there's almost no reason for
people to go spend that because this
thing starts at 5.99 and it gets pretty
much everything most people care about
from the ipad pro
except one thing so the new design of
the ipad air matches the ipad pro in
basically every way the boxy
all-aluminum shape feels rock solid it's
got these grippable flat sides the
buttons are in the same place it's nice
it has the smart connector at the back
so you can drop it in a smart folio or
even a magic keyboard case just like an
ipad pro you wanna know why because it
is the magic keyboard case for the ipad
pro and it just fits in the same case
because it has the same dimensions so
there's your trackpad there's your usbc
passthrough because guess what ipad air
also now gets usb type c
see apple it's okay to put usbc in
products without the pro in the name
it's good for everybody the quad speaker
setup that surrounds the display also
sounds phenomenal for a tablet and you
have basically the exact same bezel
thickness all the way around thin enough
to not be a problem and still look good
but thick enough to actually hold the
ipad from any angle and not have
accidental screen touches but then one
difference about that bezel is inside it
you won't find face id there's just a
regular 7 megapixel front-facing camera
up there and instead of face id touch id
is back and it's built into that power
button up top so kind of like pixel 5
they've technically gone
backwards as far as biometric
authentication methods goes but in this
world of masks that we live in uh
fingerprint reader is just as convenient
as face id sometimes more so although
with an ipad you use at home a lot where
you're not really out and wearing a mask
as much so maybe the the fingerprint
reader is just at the same level as face
id either way
not a problem it's pretty easy and quick
to get used to basically the pro tip is
register multiple fingerprints actually
that's not even a pro tip that's just
common sense but a lot of people don't
do it but for me both index fingers work
great so no matter which orientation the
ipad is in the finger i press the power
button with also unlocks it for me so
that's great and apple's done
fingerprint readers well for a while now
this one is also fast and accurate the
only little bit of friction i had
personally was i'm so used to ipad pro
that my unlock is typically touch to
wake and then swipe up and it reads my
face but of course i have to remember on
this to touch the power button which is
such a minor thing but also most people
getting ipad air aren't coming from an
ipad pro so this is a total non-issue
for on the back ipad air literally gets
the same 12 megapixel primary camera as
the ipad pro but you'll note it's just a
single camera by itself and a mic
no flash
no ultra wide
no lidar but i mean if you think about
it how often do you need an ultra wide
or a lidar sensor or even a flash for
your tablet photography i'd say pretty
much never so all of these things
missing mean almost nothing to most
people i maintain that the most common
use of ipad cameras should be document
scanning and facetime calls and these
cameras here are more than good enough
for that and then the ipad air has the
new apple pencil support it snaps onto
the side of the ipad to charge and pair
the same way as the pro so that's pretty
sweet and then inside ipad air actually
has the even newer five nanometer a14
bionic chip instead of the a12z
currently in the pro so you can actually
expect very similar sometimes even
better benchmark numbers on paper but
the point is despite its slightly lower
four gigs of ram it's gonna perform
great i've had no performance issues and
i don't expect the typical user will run
into any performance limits for a long
time so on the surface level
everything ipad pro does
ipad air
basically also does
except
refresh rate so ipad air is of course at
the standard 60 hertz that we're used to
on every other apple device except the
ones with pro motion like ipad pro which
are at 120 hertz
now if you've never seen 120 hertz which
if we're being honest most apple users
never have then 60hz is gonna look great
but it's like every time i review an
ipad i always can't help but have these
thoughts on like the state of tablets in
general and how the entire android
tablet ecosystem rose to such great
heights and then fell so far like there
used to be so much conjecture and
thoughts and interesting videos about
what the tablet os should look like and
how it should multitask and what it
should do
but now with like four out of the top
five tablets available being ipads
they're all kind of just the same
performance is fine as expected through
ipad os 14 there's plenty of ipad
optimized apps and games which is great
and it's just kind of the status quo now
the ipad pro is 120 hertz of course
speaks to people like me because i'm
personally a fan of high refresh rate
the more pixels the better
but i've always said in the past and
it's still true here apple also makes
some of the smoothest 60 hertz devices
and smoothness of course is not a
problem at all here it's standard and
actually battery life is also
potentially even better on this ipad air
because it never has to hit 120 hertz
it's just chilling at 60 and it's using
the more efficient 5 nanometer a14 chip
also it happens to come with a slightly
faster 20 watt fast charger in the box
instead of the old 18 that comes with
the ipad pro so okay i've done a lot of
comparing in this video so i'm just
going to go ahead and name
every single significant thing that you
could notice as a difference between
ipad pro
and ipad air and i'm not going to get
into like the extra 2 gigs of ram on the
pro or the slightly higher peak
brightness i'm going to stick to the
main real bullet points of why you'd
pick one or the other so you should pick
the ipad pro over the air if you want
the ultra wide camera or lidar
if you want high refresh rate 120 hertz
promotion
or
a bigger ipad because the the bigger 13
inch ipad pro is available the ipad air
only comes in the 11 inch size or 10.9
inch
but that's it for everyone else you
should get the ipad air it's it's all
the tablet you need for way less money
uh
that almost seems too simple are there
any downsides yes but they're small
obviously no bigger size is a bit of a
downside for some people like i
mentioned there's only 10.9
uh but also i'm not a fan of these
colors at all they're all super pale
pastel-ish kind of colors but i mean
this green only shows up on camera as
green because i've made a conscious
effort through this video to put it up
against things that don't overwhelm the
green it really isn't green most of the
time so i'd just get space gray this new
ipad to me more represents apple's more
interesting strategy of attacking a
wider range of prices and offering more
things at more prices we saw it with the
iphone anywhere from 399 at the sc all
the way up to 1299 at the 12 pro max
and now we see it with the ipad with the
329 dollar ipad straight all the way up
to 14.99 for the one terabyte 13 inch
ipad pro with cellular so this new ipad
takes a lot of great stuff from the pro
brings it down in price and that's why
you could call it an ipad pro killer but
really it's just living alongside it for
a lot of people
so that's pretty much it let me know
which one you would pick are you a
promotion type of person like me would
you go for the ipad pro or are you one
of those ipad air people because there's
about to be a lot of them either way
thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace